and joining us on the phone is a mayor
of Monroe County his name is George
Nugent now he is in Marathon in the
Florida Keys hello mr. mayor yeah I know
it's it's all topsy-turvy today I can't
imagine what it's like for you and your
constituents because you are being told
that you are going to get a direct hit
can you tell us how you're preparing and
what's going on right now well we've
been preparing for a week on those
people who have evacuated we'd stress
how important it is evacuate as you may
well know that we're very unique we're
Islands connected by 43 bridges that if
we were to lose one we only have one way
and one way out and all these bridges
will have to be inspected before we can
clear the roads and get heavy equipment
in here we've got two airports and Key
West and marathon and hopefully we'll
get those cleared and that they'll serve
as the staging area
but these destruction is going to be
tremendous I can hear the wind howling
outside my door right now properly in
the hundred and 10 and above miles per
hour and that's going to affect some
serious serious destruction throughout
the Florida Keys there Nugent what's the
normal population of Marathon and how
many people are there now population is
around 9,000 and I would suspect that
there's maybe another thousand people
between first responders and people that
are in shelters and last resort and in
Marathon that may be a high number I
hope it is but hopefully no one's
staying in homes we have ground-level
homes here that if people decide to stay
in them and from time to time they they
will make that wrong decision and and
pay for it not necessarily through their
life but through having to live through
miserable conditions until it's gone
that a thousand people are you worried
about their safety of course I am now
some of those people are in shelters of
last resort
we turned our high school which is rated
for a category five storm in the City of
Marathon and there are people that are
there if the building is high and it's
rated for category is the new building
so they should be fine
and we've never experienced this one
like this and especially a direct hit in
in this community so they like to fear
and we can get this storm passed this
will we'll start testing on all the
people that are built in in the city of
Marathon
Mary Mary Nugent leading up to the storm
you made it clear that you would not
call on first responders to rescue
people who did not evacuate have you
gotten calls from people who are saying
I think I need a little help now
oh of course and we have a room of
control line and after a certain time
and that time has passed that no longer
will first responders go outside
hospitals are closed there's no medical
attention for anybody think the church
right now everybody pretty much on their
own not pretty much they're on their own
and so as I said we're we're waiting for
the storm to pass I wouldn't get out see
what we can do as far as helping people
that have decided to stay and are an arm
play have you been given any timetable
on how long it will take for the storm
to pass
I realize it's very unpredictable well
as I hear right now because I we've lost
power and I don't have TV contact it's
the only contact that I have with the
rest of the world is through you guys
and I've heard it's moving about nine
miles an hour so we're looking at an
all-day affair of dealing with this
storm both the front end and back end so
we're looking at seven eight hours of
storm it's not more and where are you
exactly where are you
marathon is in the middle of the keys
the keys are 120 miles long
I realize that
are you in your home are you at City
Hall that's what I'm that's what I mean
are you at a command center I'm sorry no
I'm not I'm at a house that's about 25
feet elevated which we have our cars
parked up there it's a very fortress
type house so we can't even feel the
effects we can hear a little bit of the
effects of the wind blowing up and mayor
what kind of supplies do you have with
you we have plenty of food plenty of
water and but we've lost power we're
gonna fire up the generators here before
too long
you've lost power that's electricity but
we're we're good shape are we prepared
for at least several weeks of living
alone and who is the we you and your
family my wife and another couple all
right
well mayor Nugent we wish wish your
residents they are the very best thank
you for the latest information thank you